this morning is my birthday and last
year Brady had a fantastic surprise for
me he H the periodic table on one of my
hairs and it even got into this year's
Guinness Book of Records so this year
Brady says he's got another surprise and
I've been stuck here in my office
waiting I don't know what it is I'm
really quite excited
[Music]
congratula--
there
yeah Wow well that's wonderful
it's a periodic table that's the first
one I've had with the new elements 114
and 116 which is really terrific is that
the first thing you notice that yeah
it's really good I'm overwhelmed then
they have the main group elements that
are read and the actinides that and
lanthanides that a purple is terrific
thank you very much thank you very much
which one are you going to eat first
Oh hassium delicious
I now know even more about Hassim than I
did about everybody will eat them what
else you're going to donate them you can
donate I'm going to donate them to
everybody so the hungry students and to
to everybody else dr. doom platinum
platinum go against acne I'll be see you
can might take you mess it up like three
million times I'm gonna go for hygiene
because it's the simplest okay any
pictures visual ray Liam and knackery
what are you choosing deaf I know it's
not green I've gotta take you right now
well done show us rhenium well done
louis i Platinum's gone so i'm going to
fake palladium I'll take off I think I
surprise you I have something to make my
voice squeak oh do you thank you very
much party system cameraman my god
I'm so nervous I'm going to eat
something I would never eat in real life
but as a collection it's by far the most
terrific Kate day over anything we need
people in sweetcakes you again sorry
every time okay I'm very very touched
thank you very much indeed
and have a happy Christmas
[Music]
you